let's talk about your judge so let's
start with the dress we're gonna go
there tell me about this drab I'm
wearing Alexander Botti a and Couture
crazy yeah Couture and the funny thing
is I realized I think I've worn over the
past two Grammys he says always gets it
right for us women he just has a really
good soft touch with edge and all that
fun stuff so it felt right and we might
be the designer for the Grammys you say
in a way where it's different than say a
different red carpet well you know for
the Grammys what he does to me is he
just makes the woman feel very sexy and
you know he gives you that show factor
thing that you like you said when you
come here this is like our office or
some music so you want to shine and he
just finds the first way to put it all
together attitude sexy fun young cool
all that good stuff so he's a great guy
- I am loving your beauty look what
about your beauty looking your makeups
you like the fact um you know what I
want to push my eyes up a little bit
more tonight so we went for a little bit
more intensity in the eyes I kept my
jury very minimal because a dress it's a
piece of jewelry within itself but hair
wise I want to kind of like keep it
simple but add a little rock and roll -
and I guess I think that's what we're
kind of doing here pull it back off the
shoulders to give the dress a little bit
of a moment so that's a combination that
we have going you also have the girl's
best accessory a very handsome date
tonight is awesome you so beautiful
right these lurking around here a bi
awesome